عوده الان الى مؤتمر البنتاجون وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه معنا من مقر البنت تكون
في واشنطن مراسله جزيره فادي منصور فادي
يلخص لنا ما جاء في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
للمسؤولين الملكين
معه مارك مالي يعني الكثير من القضايا
التي يتناولها المسؤولان منها كوريا
الشماليه الصين وروسيا وغيرها ضعنا في
صورتها
المتعدده لكن هذا المؤتمر الصحفي جاء في
ختام اجتماع مجموعات الاتصال الدفاعيه
الخاصه باوكرانيا ولا شك ان الموضوع الاول
الذي طرح خلال المؤتمر الصحفي ومساله ما
حصل في هولندا الانفجار الذي وقع يوم امس
داخل حدود بولندا والاتهامات التي وجدت
الى روسيا بمسؤوليتها عن ذلك بما انها كان
الطقس في اوكرانيا بعشرات الصواريخ وزير
الدفاع الامريكي اكد اولا من الولايات
المتحده لديها خبراء على الارض تساعد
التحقيقات الهولنديه وان المعطيات
المتوفره حتى هذه اللحظه رغم ان التحقيقات
لا تزال مستمره تشير الى ان لا يمكن
مناقضه تصريحات المسؤولين البولنديين
الذين رجعوا بان ما حصل هو السقوط احد
صواريخ الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه داخل
الاراضي الهولنديه وبالتالي هذه هي
الروايه التي خرج بها وزير الدفاع
الامريكي بان الحادثه الارجح نجمات عن
صاروخ الاوكراني اثناء التصدي
روسيه لكن وزير الدفاع الامريكي كان واضحا
بان ما حصل هو ايه اشاره مره اخرى الى
تهور روسيا في هذه الحرب كما اشار وان
المسؤوليه عن هذه الحادثه تقع في نهايه
المطاف على روسيا وليس على الجانب
الاوكراني الذي يحق له اي دافع عن نفسه
اشار الى ان الاجتماع اليوم خرج بنتائج
ملموسه مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا
والتزامات بتدريب القوات الاوكرانيه خلال
السنه المقبله كان لافتا تصريحات ايضا
لقائد الاركان الامريكي الجنرال مايك من
الذي اعتبر ان روسيا اخفقت في هذه الحرب
اخفقت ستراتيجيا خسرت استراتيجيا وخسرت
تكتيكيا ولم تستطع ان تحقق اي من اهدافها
داخل اوكرانيا واشار الى ان فصلي الخريف
والشتاء ربما سوف يؤديان الى تباته
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه قال ان القوات
الروسيه تحت 20% الان من وادي الاوكرانيه
اراضي بطوط سمعت كيلو متر وبعمق ما بين 75
الى 80 كم وقال اذا مهمه القوات
الاوكرانيه بالنجاح في طرد القوات الروسيه
بالكامل من الاراضي الاوكرانيه صعبه ولكن
لم يستبعد ان يكون هناك ربما تسويه عبر
الخيار السياسي ليس بالضروره في الوقت
الراهن السريع وهناك قضايا اخرى بطبيعه
الحال الشرطي اليها ليس لدينا الوقت على
ما يبدو لبحثهام